alex smith
suffered a serious broken leg during the
2018
season infection that that nearly
claimed his life and he has worked his
way back worked his way
back he said last week he's cleared for
football activities he still hasn't
passed a physical
in washington they're taking their time
with him yesterday peter
quarterbacks coach ken zampeezy had some
very positive things to say about alex
smith his attitude how he learns and
what it's going to take to get him back
on the field can he protect himself
they're going to watch him in drills
watch him in 11 on 11 what does he do
when a guy breaks through can he move
away like he used to
but if this guy still has it physically
he's only 36. now 36 used to be old
as quarterbacks went not anymore not
with tom brady turning 43 in three days
i'm fascinated by the possibility in
this year
with everything that is in turmoil and
you look at what alex smith did with the
49ers in 2011
in the lockout year when the 49ers were
supposedly rebuilding and jim harbaugh
was in his first year as head coach
and the 49ers were within a muffed punt
or two of making it to the super bowl
you got ron rivera new coach trying to
stabilize things
if alex smith is healthy enough to
protect himself and play like he did
before the injury and i know that's a
big if
i i don't know how you don't give him
every chance to win that starting job
over dwayne haskins especially for this
year
you know the washington quarterback
situation is absolutely fascinating
you got the starter for ron rivera in
carolina last year
who when they brought him in this year
i just said well you know i i i my
feeling is he's got a better chance to
start
than dwayne haskins when there's no off
season activity because rivera knows him
better
now you get alex smith and you basically
i i i said this to uh a
talk show guy down there the other day
but i said that
this is really of all the amazing
stories happening right now
in the nfl this is the most amazing
for alex smith after watching that
stefania bell espn
incredible e60 story
uh about with cameras in the room
looking at his leg that i could have
sworn they were going to have to
amputate his leg
and now he's on the active slash
physically unable to perform list
for for people who don't know exactly
what that means
let me tell you he can do everything
that any player can
can do in practice over the next month
other than to practice okay
so but he can do everything else he can
run he can lift he can do all the drills
you know he can be in the one-on-ones
and
and
all this stuff he can i mean he can
throw my whole thing is
it's amazing to me that he's gotten this
far and
mike you're right i don't assume he's
gonna win this job
but the fact that he's even in
competition
he's even a thought for this job to me
is amazing
yeah i i cannot believe it it's a great
story even if he never puts a helmet on
again
but the idea that that he's on the
verge of being cleared to practice and
that they're going to evaluate him
carefully and see if he can still play
like he used to
i mean look this is a guy who has been
through
offensive coordinator after offensive
coordinator um
and to the point where the offensive
coordinator
now in washington scott turner is the
son
of the guy who was alex smith's
offensive coordinator his second year in
the league back in 2006
norv turner so he's learned offenses
he's relearned offense he's
unlearned offenses he's he's always
found a way to get it
done and starting in 2011 that year with
the 49ers
he became a better quarterback you know
it was a good five six seasons before he
emerged
as a guy that we look at as a top half
of the nfl quarterback
and then he got to kansas city and it
worked out very well for the
for the chiefs with alex smith until
they decided to go all in for patrick
mahomes
and even then smith had a great final
season in kansas city so you know
you take that broken leg out of the mix
and alex smith is still going strong as
the starting quarterback in washington
and maybe jay gruden is still the head
coach they were six and four i believe
when smith got injured in 2018 which is
you know better than most washington
teams have been over the past 21 years
that daniel snyder's owned the franchise
so
i just look i i root for great stories
and this is nothing against wayne
haskins who may have a very long
and productive and successful career and
by all indications he's checking all the
boxes this off season
he's rising to the challenge that was
created for him by ron rivera
but man it's hard not to root for alex
smith to get back on the field and play
like he used to play and
really put the capper on one of the most
inspiring stories we've ever seen
you know two things about what you just
said number one
isn't it amazing that um after alex
smith has one of the best 10 seasons
in football in 2017
uh andy reid and brett veach trade them
because
essentially they want to play a kid who
they've only seen one game
the one game he played against denver i
find that
to be uh you know someday when andy reid
i assume he'll go into canton but
someday when andy reid goes into canton
that'll be a story i will long remember
about
there's more to coaching a football team
than just coaching and there's decisions
that you have to make
and that was a great one but the other
one i would say is
alex smith at his peak has been
a truly underrated player his playoff
duel with drew brees
uh you know in san francisco a few years
ago
when joe staley gets out on the edge and
has the best
pulling run block for a quarterback i
think i've ever
seen in my life you know when alex smith
runs around for
for the touchdown that game where he
went absolutely
toe to toe with a transcendent
quarterback in drew brees
how great he was that day how great he
was in 2000 2017
with the kansas city chiefs to me
i will alway i will feel bad if
whenever he does leave the game if
anybody thinks
that alex smith really didn't live up
to the billing because okay look there's
been a lot of first
pick quarterbacks who've been better
okay no question about it
but he overcame a horrible team
for a long time in san francisco and
he stuck with it and has had some
extremely good days
big days in the nfl you know you
mentioned 2017
and i think the chiefs knew all along
what they had in patrick mahomes we had
travis kelsey on the show that year and
he just went on and on about mahomes and
and there had to be a temptation when
the chief sputtered the middle of the
season
to put my homes out there we were
calling for it i wanted to see what my
homes could do i saw enough in
pre-season i wanted to see what he could
do
alex smith felt like he plateaued but
but to his credit andy reid's loyalty to
smith
you know he wanted to handle it the
right way he didn't want to just
summarily bench alex smith
he wanted to let him finish out the job
and see what he could do in 2017 and
then they moved on but they knew what
they had in patrick mahomes
uh they they knew from the practice
field what the rest of us were going to
see
and i kind of wish we still would have
seen it in 2017 because who knows what
the chiefs would have done
if mahomes just lands on our radar
screen out of the blue like that
in november of a given year but that
what that wasn't what happened because
of the i think the loyalty and the good
feeling toward alex smith who's always
been the consummate pro
never been a problem anywhere he's been
he's always busted his butt he's worked
and he's worked and he's worked
and that's the attitude that has got him
back to the brink of being cleared to
practice after an injury that should
have ended his career
could have claimed his leg could have
claimed his life
so we're rooting for alex smith this
season hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports